Iranian climber who took Parts in an  international competition without  wearing a headscarf has arrived back in  Tehran  a large crowd gathered to welcome the 33  year old elnaz rakabi who left the Asia  championship in South Korea early  despite concerns that she could face  arrest on her return earlier this  morning she told reporters that her  actions were unintentional  um  if I want to explain I should say that  everything conforms to what I've  explained on the internet it was  completely unintentional I think my  Instagram story fully explained this  unfortunately I came back to Iran with  peace of mind although I went through a  lot of tension and stress  so far thank God nothing has happened  and of course this is the occasion Mr  okabe is referring to it was the first  time she was seen competing without  wearing a headscarf which is the usual  requirement for any female athlete  representing Iran